have you ever noticed when you ask
someone to talk about a change they're
making for the better in their personal
lives they're often really energetic
whether it's training for a marathon
picking up an old hobby or learning a
new skill for most people self
transformation projects occupy a very
positive emotional space self
transformation is empowering energizing
even exhilarating I mean just take a
look at some of the titles of self-help
books awaken the giant within practicing
the power of now or here's a great one
we can all relate to you are a badass
how to stop doubting your greatness and
start living an awesome life when it
comes to self transformation you can't
help but get a sense of the excitement
but there is another type of
transformation that occupies a very
different emotional space the
transformation of organizations if
you're like most people when you hear
the words our organization is going to
start a transformation you're thinking
oh layoffs the blood drains from your
face your mind goes into overdrive
frantically searching for someplace to
run and hide well you can run but you
really can't hide most of us spend the
majority of our waking hours involved in
organizations and due to changes in
globalization changes it's due to
advances in technology and other factors
the reality is is our organizations are
constantly having to adapt in fact I
call this the era of always-on
transformation when I shared this idea
with my wife Nicola she said always-on
transfer
Meishan that sounds exhausting and that
may be exactly what you're thinking and
you would be right particularly if we
continue to approach the transformation
of organizations the way we always have
been but because we can't hide we need
to sort out two things first why is
transformation so exhausting and second
how do we fix it
first of all let's acknowledge that
change is hard
people naturally resist change
especially when it's imposed on them but
there are things that organizations do
that make change even harder and more
exhausting for people than it needs to
be
first of all leaders often wait too long
to act as a result everything is
happening in crisis mode which of course
tends to be exhausting or given the
urgency what they'll do is they'll just
focus on the short-term results but that
doesn't give any hope for the future or
they'll just take a superficial one-off
approach hoping that they can return
back to business as usual as soon as the
crisis is over this kind of approach is
kind of the way some students approach
preparing for standardized tests in
order to get test scores to go up
teachers will end up teaching to the
test now that approach can work test
results often do go up but it fails the
fundamental goal of Education to prepare
students to succeed over the long term
so given these obstacles what can we do
to transform the way we transform
organisations so rather than being
exhausting it's actually empowering and
energizing to do that we need to focus
on five strategic imperatives
all of which have one thing in common
putting people first the first
imperative for putting people first is
to inspire through purpose most
transformations have financial and
operational goals these are important
and they can be energizing to leaders
but they tend not to be very motivating
to most people in the organization
to motivate more broadly the
transformation needs to connect with a
deeper sense of purpose
take Lego the LEGO Group has become an
extraordinary global company under their
very capable leadership they've actually
undergone a series of transformations
while each of these has had a very
specific focus the North Star linking
and guiding all of them has been Legos
powerful purpose inspire and develop the
builders of tomorrow expanding globally
it's not about increasing sales but
about giving millions of additional
children access to Lego building bricks
investment in innovation it's not about
developing new products but about
enabling more children to experience the
joy of learning through Play not
surprisingly that deep sense of purpose
tends to be highly motivating to Legos
people
the second imperative for putting people
first is to go all in too many
transformations are nothing more than
headcount cutting exercises layoffs
under the guise of transformation in the
face of relentless competition it may
well be that you will have to take the
painful decision to downsize the
organization just as you may have to
lose some weight in order to run a
marathon but losing weight alone will
not get you across the finish line with
a winning time to win you need to go all
in you need to go all in
rather than just cutting costs you need
to think about initiatives that will
enable you to win in the medium-term
initiatives to drive growth actions that
will fundamentally change the way the
company operates and very importantly
investments to develop the leadership
and the talent the third imperative for
putting people first is to enable people
with the capabilities that they need to
succeed during the transformation and
beyond over the years I've competed in a
number of triathlons you know frankly
I'm not that good
but I do have one distinct capability
I am remarkably fast at finding my bike
by the time I finish the swim almost all
the bikes are already gone real
triathletes know that each leg the swim
the bike the run really requires
different capabilities different tools
different skills different techniques
likewise when we transform organizations
we need to be sure that we're giving our
people the skills and the tools they
need along the way Cronos a global
software company recognized the need to
transfer from building products software
products to building software as a
service to enable its people to take
that transformation first of all they
invested in new tools that would enable
their employees to monitor the usage of
the features as well as customer
satisfaction with the new service they
also invested in in skill development so
that their employees would be able to
resolve customer service problems on the
spot and very importantly they also
reinforced the collaborative behaviors
that would be required to deliver an
end-to-end seamless customer experience
because of these investments rather than
feeling overwhelmed by the
transformation Cronos employees
actually felt energized and empowered in
their new roles in the era of always-on
transformation changes a constant my
fourth imperative therefore is to
instill a culture of continuous learning
when Satya Nadella became the CEO of
Microsoft in February 2014 he embarked
on an ambitious transformation journey
to prepare the company could to compete
in a mobile-first cloud-first world
this included changes to strategy the
organization and very importantly the
culture Microsoft's culture at the time
was one of silos an internal competition
not exactly conducive to learning
Nadella took this head-on he rallied his
leadership around his vision for a
living learning culture shifting from a
fixed mindset where your role was to
show up as the smartest person in the
room to a growth mindset where your role
was to listen to learn and to bring out
the best in people while early days
Microsoft employees already know to
shift in the culture clear evidence of
Microsoft putting people first my fifth
and final imperative is specifically for
leaders in a transformation a leader
needs to have a vision a clear roadmap
with milestones and then you need to
hold people accountable for results in
other words you need to be directive but
in order to capture the hearts and minds
of people you also need to be inclusive
inclusive leadership is critical to
putting people first I live in the San
Francisco Bay Area and right now our
basketball team is the best in the
league we won the 2015 championship and
we're favored to win again this year
there are many explanations for this
they have some fabulous players but one
of the key reasons is their head coach
Steve Kerr is an inclusive
leader when kur came to the Warriors in
2014 the Warriors were looking for a
major transformation they hadn't won a
national championship since 1975 Kerr
came in and he had a clear vision and he
immediately got to work from the outset
he reached out and engaged the players
and the staff he created an environment
of open debate and solicited suggestions
during games he would often ask what are
you seeing that I'm missing one of the
best examples of this came in Game four
the 2015 finals the Warriors were down
two games to one
when Kerr made the decision to change
the starting lineup a bold move by any
measure the Warriors won the game and
went on to win the championship and it
is widely viewed that that move was the
pivotal move in their victory
interestingly it wasn't actually kurz
idea it was the idea of his 28 year old
assistant Nick who ran because of curs
leadership style who Ren felt
comfortable bringing the idea forward
and Kerr not only listened but he
implemented the idea and then afterwards
gave Iran all the credit actions all
consistent with kurz highly inclusive
approach to leadership in the era of
always-on transformation organizations
are always going to be transforming but
doing so does not have to be exhausting
we owe it to ourselves to our
organizations and to society more
broadly to boldly transform our approach
to transformation to do that
we need to start putting people first
thank you